bonjour amadou fat joe varie versier
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors coup d'état en guinée en guinée
pardon tout d'abord est ce que c'est un
coup d'état qui vous surprend
écoutez non c'est le coup contre les
régimes condé ne me surprend pas du tout
parce que la situation politique et je
suis économique et même d'abord il faut
le rappeler également les contradictions
au sein du système politique guina qui
est un régime prétoriens dans la
contradiction au sein de la relation
entre l'exécutif et l'institution
militaire était telle que les choses
devenait intenable pour le régime donc
il s'agit aujourd'hui d'un coup contre
le régime ou qu'il fallait attendre que
par des manifestations de rue le régime
se fragilise davantage compte tenu
justement des mesures liées par exemple
à la hausse des prix du carburant au
système de ponction que les régimes a
mis en place pour essayer de renflouer
les caisses de l'état donc il y avait là
quand même une conjonction de situations
qui faisaient que le régime depuis le
coup de force constitutionnel du 22 mars
fragiliser davantage mais ce qui est
important de noter ce sont les
contradictions au sein du système
politique guinée lui-même ou alpha condé
depuis 2018 a sectionné l'armée un des
groupes qui sont qui sont favorables à
son régime afin de protéger le siège
présidentiel donc à renforcer certains
groupes économiquement et militairement
jusqu à les doter de capacités de
nuisance dont lui-même s'en est rendu
compte cet aspect car l'occurrence des
groupements des forces spéciales qui l'a
voulu marginalisés au profit de nouveaux
groupes ou de formations politiques donc
aujourd'hui à ses contradictions sein de
l'armée qui fait que le régime politique
finalement n'a pas pu tenir comme on dit
son troisième mandat vous le disiez à
l'instant un gouvernement a contesté par
la rue déjà depuis plusieurs temps
maintenant qu'est-ce qui a précipité
ce coup d'état quelles sont les
dernières actualités qui ont fait que ce
coup d'état a eu lieu maintenant
d'écouter d'abord vous l'avez rappelé
dans l'introduction c'est à dire que le
le colonel mady doumbouya avait
l'ambition d'autonomiser
c'est ses forces pourquoi les raisons
pour l'instant ne sont pas tout à fait
tout à fait officielle mais il ya quand
même eu une suspicion de la part du
régime de voir le groupement des forces
spéciales être autonome par rapport
justement au tout puissant ministre de
la défense à l'ex ministre dont deux
comme ça désormais mois médiane est donc
une fois encore ce sont ces
contradictions sur le plan stratégique
là où on voit que le régime politique
guinéen est là dessus et c'est à dire
c'est pas le propre d'alpha condé le
régime politique depuis
1958 est fondée sur un soutien militaire
sur une légitimité du corps politique
afin du corps militaire on voit que
justement cet usage de l'institution
militaire dans une optique de protection
du siège présidentiel a justement
générer des contradictions au sein même
de l'institution militaire des
contradictions qui ont finalement eu
raison du pouvoir de condé lui-même dont
là dessus c'est une leçon aujourd'hui
que les guinéens doivent tirer en termes
d'organisation des rapports l'exécutif
est l'institution militaire c'est à dire
que la meilleure façon de légitimer un
pouvoir politique c'est de consacrer la
souveraineté du peuple or depuis les
indépendances la guinée n'a pas du tout
rendu possible une société où la
souveraineté du peuple aurait eu pour
avantage de légitimer le pouvoir
politique ce qu'il dit aussi pour
terminer que finalement il n'ya pas
d'état en guinée y a pas d'état parce
que justement six à vingt états nous
aurions eu des institutions politiques
et et un cadre juridique susceptible
d'organiser de manière neutre et
pacifique les lutte pour la conquête du
pouvoir de sorte que nous n'aurions pas
eu par exemple des éléments contestés et
contestables comme par exemple troisième
mandat qui par ailleurs nous montre que
sont les phénomènes de pratique
autoritaire du pouvoir qui est
conduisent le régime à se radicaliser et
a plongé la vie commune dans un cycle de
violences qui a la foi abîme des vies
mais aussi conduit l
des régimes à la fin et qui sont
dramatiques vous parler du fait qu'il
n'y ait pas d'état en guinée le fait que
la souveraineté du peuple ne soit pas à
respecter actuellement sur place c'est
ce qui avec le nouvel homme fort le
lieutenant colonel mamadou mbaye a est
ce que cette souveraineté du peuple
pourrait finir par exister
écoutez c'est l'espoir aujourd'hui que
nourrissent beaucoup de guînes est
rappelons le canal alpha condé avait
nourri aussi un espoir et c'est
d'ailleurs le vainement la situation
tragique du pays actuellement c'est
qu'alpha condé c'est inédit dans
l'histoire politique de la guinée
conakry c'est le premier président
démocratiquement
démocratiquement élu en 2010 ce qui se
fait en jeu débarquer du pouvoir alors
qu'il est vivant sékou touré il y avait
un coup de temps 84 l'armée a pris le
pouvoir à la mort de lansana conté
également eu un coup d'état et dadis
camara ya vu un coup d'état donc la
guinée camilla bon on ne parle pas d'une
tradition mais a quand même des
pratiques de coup d'état qui souvent ont
échoué et d'un autre temps réussi mais
alpha condé c'est la première fois où le
président est un exercice en tout cas la
sanction et qui se fait qu'ils se
passent débarquer donc l'espoir
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas que qu'on
applaudisse la venue de l'armée bien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une liesse
populaire que les gens quelque part sont
contents de voir que le régime qui a qui
a manifesté une soeur de rei devant les
tentatives de négociations depuis
septembre 2020 dissuader alpha condé le
symbole d'un troisième nous mêmes les
jeux nous avions signé une tribune dans
jeune afrique où nous avons contacté le
régime de l'époque pour le proposer des
solutions pour nous sortir de la
violence mais ils n'ont jamais prêté
oreille un nouveau recommandations et
aujourd'hui donc ce qu'on espère c'est
que par delà la prise du pouvoir par la
force c'est que la guinée se
réapproprient leur capacité collective à
faire société donc l'armée nous avons
besoin de l'armée des forces vives des
intellectuels des universitaires pour qu
ensemble pour une première fois dans
l'histoire de ce pays nous pensons enfin
nous pensions nos mots et que nous
questionnons en posant la question
fondamentale est préalable à toute
logique électorale celle de savoir
comment organiser la coexistence sociale
sous les rapports de la justice de la
liberté et d'égalité cette question
aujourd'hui que l'armée elle doit
véritablement poser est donc convoqué
tout le corps politique et bien sûr les
universitaires intellectuels qui la
merci beaucoup amadou sadio barry merci
d'autant plus inquiet très très tôt chez
vous au québec quatre heures du matin
donc merci de vous est élevé pour nous
rappeler que vous êtes professeur de
philosophie au québec et chercheur en
ethnique des relations internationales
est aussi auteur du livre et c'est sur
la fondation politique de la guinée
merci beaucoup